Today's conversation may be the last, so please do
n't ask me just one thing.If you
were in a more desperate situation than anyone else, and you took this test seriously, you'd be able to
survive without being expelled, right?  Even if I leave, are you
satisfied? Or do you want me to tell you the secret to survival? No. If I
ask, I
might fall into your scheme, but
thank you. Seeing you accept reality, I think
I can be a little more prepared.
If it's inevitable that someone will be expelled, all you have to do is judge who's
suitable and make a decision.You might end up being
rejected.Then that's the extent of
my ability.It
just sounds like a joke.I'll
cut someone.  That's how
difficult it can be.I've
been merciless to students who hold me back ever since I entered school.What do you know?I
know what you're all about.Your weakness
is visible in every phrase you say.  You can't even face your own brother.
Takashi knows how determined you are. In the end, you don't know what to do.
Besides, you're already immersed
in the lukewarm waters of your class. Try to
remain calm.  How can you do that?
Hey, the only one who can do that is Rei and Sakayanagi, who
only looks at her classmates. No matter how arrogant you
say it, there really isn't anything you can do about it.
Why do
you think that? After all, you're going to be expelled from school.  I'm just accepting it calmly. Don't let
this machine pass you by. I
guess I don't want Ryuen to drop out of school.